[Musique]
1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Salut à tous, nouvelle heure sujet. J'ai
36 ans, je suis né en 1982. Je suis donc
techniquement un enfant des années 90 au
sens où j'ai davantage grandi dans les
années 90 que dans les années 80. J'ai
connu l'explosion des mangas en France,
de leur arrivée jusqu'à leur
popularisation par le club de roté et
leur quasi disparition de la télé à la
fin des années 90. Oui, parce que je
fais un aparté mais si vous êtes pas de
ma génération, vous pouvez pas vous
rendre compte à quel point les animés
japonais s'étaient omniprésents dans les
années 90. Il y avait des mangas
partout. Le club de roté c'était 80 %
d'animé japonais et ça a duré jusqu'au
gros mouvement antimanga de la fin des
années 90 porté par la presse française
et certains politiques qui jugaient
qu'il y avait trop d'œuvres japonaises,
que les mangas c'étaient violents et
abrutissants, ce qui aboutira à leur
quasi disparition des chaînes
principales. Alors après la seconde
raison, c'est parce que AB Production
venait de lancer ABAT et que TF1 aimait
pas trop la concurrence. Bref, en tant
qu'enfant des années 90, j'ai aussi vu
plein de courants musicaux. Les gens de
ma génération ont vu la naissance et la
mort des boys band, l'apparition ou en
tout cas l'explosion de la techno, de la
dance, du RnB, la naissance ou du moins
en tout cas l'explosion aussi du hip
hop. Et on se rend pas bien compte mais
dans les années 90, il y a eu plus de
courants musicaux majeurs que dans les
20 années qui ont suivi. Ma génération a
aussi vu l'apparition des premiers
téléphones portables, des premiers
smartphones d'internet, d'abord limité
puis popularisé avec AOL.
Et tout ça est arrivé quand j'étais au
lycée. Et évidemment tout le monde sait
que notre génération est bien mieux que
celle qui a suivi
quoi. Mais c'est vrai. Non mais je je
veux dire objectivement. Bref, tout ce
que je viens de dire, on en a déjà
largement parlé dans cette émission,
mais je sais ce qu'une partie d'entre
vous attend hein. Vous qui êtes
légèrement plus jeune que nous, qui êtes
né dans la fin des années 90 ou début
2000 qu'on appelle les millennials d'un
ton un peu méprisant. Vous qui avez
grandi avec des choses formidables comme
la téléréalité, l'autotune ou le
terrorisme, enfant des années 2000,
cette vidéo est pour toi. Il est temps
de voyager dans le temps et d'aller voir
à quoi ressemblait ton enfance.
Max compagnie
de
les
jeut
[Musique]
des années 2000. À cette période, je
viens de commencer mes études
supérieures. J'ai donc un peu lâché
l'affaire avec les dessins animés. C'est
pour ça que j'ai pris une alarme qui
sonnera à chaque fois que je dirais un
truc de vieux coin et gris. La fin des
années 90 marque un événement majeur
dans les émissions jeunesse. C'est la
fin de l'époque du club de roté remplacé
à la place par TF puis TFU plus tard.
Ces nouvelles émissions tronquent donc
les animés japonais pour nous abreuver à
la place de Ftoon américain en
provenance de Nickeloon. Et tout ça, je
rappelle, ça fait suite au râ de la
presse et des politiques sur la
surabondance de dessins animés étrangers
dans le club de roté.
Non mais attends, si on remplace les
dessins animés japonais par les dessins
animés américains, c'est c'est toujours
des dessins animés étrangers ?
Ouais, c'est vrai. Ouais, mais vu que
eux ils sont blancs, ben je suppose que
ça compte pas.
Sur la 2, DK TV a été remplacé par KD2A.
Sur France 3, on galère un petit peu
hein puisque après les minium qui
avaient tenu la baraque pendant des
années, la chaîne galère à trouver une
recette qui fonctionne. Donc on passe en
2003 à TH3.
Ah
merci Théo.
Dégueulasse.
Puis à France truc et enfin à Touan
quelques années plus tard. Sur la scène,
on a les Zouu qui tiennent le coup
depuis quelques années maintenant. Et
enfin M6 a gardé le cap avec M6 Kid.
Évidemment chaque chaîne avait ses
cartoon phares. M6 avait Yu-Gi-Oh dont
on a déjà parlé, mais il y avait
également Sakura, chasseuse de cartes.
Ben, ils aimait bien les cartes he sur
M6. Bref, Sakura, ce dessin animé
fantastique où Sakura, une enfant de 8
ans est amoureuse de Mathieu, un mec
beaucoup plus vieux.
Tiens, attrape.
Oh, Vanille, un garçon qui t'offre des
bonbons, ça cache sûrement quelque
chose.
Oh, c'est trop mignon.
Allô la police ! Étrangement, je
regardais cette série mais en y
repensant, il y avait quand même
vachement de trucs chelous pour une
école primaire. Ouais, parce que donc on
a Sakura qui est amoureuse de Mathieu,
Mathieu qui est amoureux de Thomas, le
frère de Sakura, Lionel qui est amoureux
de Sakura, Tiffanie qui est amoureuse de
Sakura, Stéphanie est amoureuse de
Lionel,
Stéphanie est la cousine de Lionel.
Lionel et moi sommes fiancés.
Et ça se passe au Japon ou nordpadé ? Et
puis [ __ ] je comprends pourquoi c'est
un des derniers dessins animés à avoir
francisé les noms.
Laurent
Julien.
Ah oui, je crois qu'il y a une histoire
avec des cartes aussi. Et c'est
peut-être mon imagination ou je dois
avoir une métaphore dans ce bâton qui
Non non non, laissez tomber. Tur M6
d'ailleurs on trouvait tout des fois
c'était pas trop mal genre Man black
mais il y avait aussi beaucoup de séries
que je trouvais horrible genre Godzilla,
Gadget Boy, cette espèce d'infamè de
sortie d'une décharge publique ou la
famille de la jungle.
Élis de la jungle. Ah oui, peut-être que
vous vous aimiez bien la famille de la
jungle, mais moi déjà graphiquement, je
trouvais ça horrible. Et surtout cette
série, le seul souvenir que j'en ai,
c'est ce personnage insupportable.
OK, là, j'ai pas forcément pris le
meilleur extrait, mais je vous jure que
c'est vachement mieux que toute cette
Japimation de merde là. Et puisqu'on est
dans les trucs horribles, on passe sur
France 3 où il paraît que la série
suivante a donné des cauchemars à plein
de
gens.Angela, c'est mon nom.
Bienvenue à mon émission.
Je m'appelle Angela.
Oh, ça va, je vois pas Angela Anaconda.
Visiblement, ce truc, c'est un peu le
télécha. Alors, ça raconte les aventures
d'Angela, une fille issue d'un milieu
modeste qui vit sa petite vie avec ses
amis. Après, hormis le fait que les
personnages ont l'air de sortir d'un
camp de concentration et d'être atteint
d'un cancer incurable en face terminale,
non, c'est tout. C'est tout ce que je
voulais dire. Non, sérieusement, après
je comprends un peu ce que les gens
ressentent. Le look des personnages est
terrifiant. Les gros plans sont juste
cauchemar desques. Solution. Si je dis à
tous mes amis ce que contient la liste,
la liste de
le bébé qu'on voit dans certains
épisodes, je jure que c'est le fils de
Satan en personne. Et dernier truc, vous
savez que la
elle est en classe spéciale Angela
Anaconda ou un truc comme ça. Mais
pourquoi tous ces amis ont l'air
complètement tebé ?
[Musique]
Est-ce que c'est une chèvre ? Bref,
Angela Anaconda, je sais pas, c'est
bizarre certes, mais ça vaut pas
l'horreur d'imaginer que soudainement
votre fourchette peut se mettre à vous
parler ou que votre téléphone possède
une tête de fétus avorté. Enfin bref,
tant qu'on est sur France 3, on continue
avec une autre série et j'ai même pas
besoin de donner le nom parce que rien
qu'à la musique que vous entendez là en
fond sonore, vous êtes déjà en train de
sauter sur votre canapé.
On ira on saura sauver notre existence,
se donner une chance de tout est passé.
On ira on saura sauver notre résistance
pour refaire
avance sans danger.
Code Lyoko sorti en 2003, une série
française qui a eu un succès absolument
fou. On y retrouve donc les aventures
d'une bande de lycéen composée de Yumi,
la petite fille gothique de ton voisin
venue étudier en France. Jérémy, le
cliché du Nord qui a 13 ans mais qui a
déjà inventé un truc qui permet de
voyager entre les dimensions. Ou le
sportif ténébreux et OD, un chipmunk qui
a pris forme humaine.
Je viens de débarquer dans le collège et
le proviseur m'a collé d'office avec
toi. Faites pas cette tête, tu verras,
je suis un garçon sympa, hyper cool et
génial. C'est canon.
Oh ouais, c'est du sang effectivement.
Bah oui, et j'ai pas précisé mais il y a
pas un problème de morphologie là ?
[Musique]
Donc l'épisode 1 commence au lycée alors
qu'un nounours visiblement est infecté
par un virus informatique ce qui lui
permet de prendre vie et d'aller mat des
culottes d'adolescentes.
Le trogan classique qu'on chope sur un
site de Warz quoi.
Oui, vous savez c'est ces virus
informatiques là qui se transmettent par
l'air et qui coulent à travers les
ampoules et qui permettent à des objets
en tissu de devenir gigantesque. Et
d'ailleurs, c'est quoi ? Ils se font
attaquer par un nounours géant comme ça
et puis à l'épisode 2, tout le monde va
reprendre sa vie normale. Attends
tiens, prends cette enveloppe. Bref,
heureusement, le groupe de lycéens conçu
a la capacité de plonger dans un monde
virtuel intitulé Lioko pour s'y battre
contre Xana. C'est le nom du virus. Mais
pour ça, il faut d'abord aller dans leur
base secrète. Allez et saluez qui vous
savez pour moi
[Musique]
leur base secrète.
J'ai j'ai dit leur base secrète.
[Musique]
Fallait peut-être envisager de prendre
le bus he si c'était si loin. Non, parce
que il faisait jour quand même quand ils
sont partis, hein.
[Musique]
Ouais. Heureusement qu'il y a la musique
parce que sinon on ferait chier.
Bref, à l'intérieur du monde virtuel,
les graphismes de la série changent.
[Musique]
Et là, on y a une aspiration clairement
très jeux vidéo, Matrix, Tron et
compagnie. Donc tout ce petit monde est
aidé par Aita cyber WFU du nerd. Et donc
alors que dehors le nounours détruit la
moitié de l'école, dans le monde
virtuel, Aelita finit par accéder à la
tour contrôlée par Xana et y battre le
virus en entrant dans le cœur et en
tapant le mot de passe code
et ça change jamais hein. J'ai maté
toute la série, c'est toujours le même
mot de passe. Et Lioko c'est le nom du
monde virtuel donc c'est un peu comme si
ton mot de passe pour aller sur internet
c'était internet.
Modit comme il m'a encore battu mais je
les aurai. Dites patron, on pourrait
juste changer le mot de passe.
Je ne peux pas, je n'ai plus accès à mon
adresse email.
Au passage, on sent bien l'inspiration
japonaise de tous cartoon, notamment
dans le coup classique des deux héros
qui s'aiment mais qui veulent pas se
l'avouer pendant 40 saisons.
Je euh Ça va bien toi ? Ah
mais baiser [ __ ]
E Oh c'est des collégiens
et c'est des millénials. Il fument à
l'âge de 4 ans. Je l'ai vu à la télé.
Bref, il y a aussi le classique
recyclage des plats à l'infini.
clairement c'est l'écologie et dans
quelques autres petits détails.
[Musique]
En même temps, Yumi dans le dessin
animé, elle est japonaise,
ça les attire. Regardez Sorina.
Oui.
E
donc bref, le méchant est battu mais
l'école est à moitié détruite et comme
tout le monde a vu le nounours géant
tout cassé et qu'on peut pas laisser ça
comme ça parce que ça serait trop chiant
d'installer une continuité entre les
épisodes. Seb ouvre l'enveloppe.
Parz pour le retour dans le passé Yumi ?
Waouh ! Tu avais raison magic.
Après en réalité tout ça a été expliqué
dans l'épisode 0 qui est en fait
l'épisode 66 parce que qui ça intéresse
la logique pendant plus de 60 épisodes ?
On apprend dans cet épisode spécial les
origines de Xana et on y découvre que le
petit nerd a réactivé par accident un
ordinateur du futur dans l'usine
abandonnée voisine. Mais comment tu peux
réactiver un ordi super secret comme ça
? Même le Windows familial de ma mère,
il y a un mot de passe dessus. J'en ai
mis un, c'était 1 2 3 4.
Enfin bref, donc il trouve ça par hasard
alors qu'il y allait à la base pour
J'avais dans l'idée que j'y trouvera à
coup sûr tout plein de vieux trucs de
pièces mécaniques de circuit électrique
pour voler des fils de cuivre et surtout
à quel moment aucun des gamins se dit on
va peut-être prévenir des gens
compétents et pas pas faire juste mumuse
avec le réacteur nucléaire parce que
c'est rigolo.
Moi je dis il faut prévenir les
autorités il presto.
Oui
oui et moi aussi c'est beaucoup trop
dangereux.
Oui.
Non. Je lance juste un programme en
espérant ne pas me tromper. Et quel
programme ? Retour vers le passé.
Quoi ? C'est tout ?
Attendez, je lance le programme facilité
scénaristique pour écriture feignante.
Bref, la série est plutôt pas belle,
mais mon gros reproche, c'est que le
scénario ne change jamais.
Étape 1, au lycée. Étape 2, Xana attaque
avec à chaque fois un truc plus débile
que l'épisode précédent. Genre OK, j'ai
compris que Xana c'est un virus
informatique qui manipule l'électricité,
d'accord. Mais là,
j'ai commencé à flotter dans les airs.
Rupture du champ gravitationnel.
Résultat, un état d'esanteur local et
spontané. Tu vois un rapport entre
électricité et apesanteur ? Les champs
magnétiques.
Des explications du professeur Müller.
En terme scientifique, on appelle ça une
grosse connerie.
des explications du professeur Müller.
Bref, étape 3, montage où tout le monde
se rend au labo. Et après, étape 4, il
faut escorter ailita jusqu'à la tour
pour battre le méchant. Ce dessin animé,
en fait, c'est quatre saisons basées sur
une quête d'escorte.
Notre série a super bien marché et tout
le monde a aimé. Je propose qu'on soit
raisonnable et qu'on arrête là. Il ne
faut pas pousser trop loin juste pour
faire de l'argent. Et oui, mais
malheureusement on n'est pas dans le bon
univers.
[Musique]
En général, les trucs qui finissent par
évolution, ça finit mal. Bref, code
lyoko évolution. Alors, c'est pas
vraiment le sujet puisqu'on est censé
parler de dessins animés. Ce truc est
sorti en 2013 en plus, donc c'est pas si
vieux. Du coup, je garde ça en réserve
pour un prochain hors sujet.
Génial. Tu en as toutes tes plans
foireux comme ça.
J'en connais un qui a beaucoup redoublé.
Enfin bref, donc cette série, c'est le
classique accident de la saison de trop.
Le caractère des personnages a
complètement changé. Aita est devenue
dépressive. Les deux acteurs qui jouent
Ulrick et William se ressemblent
tellement que j'arrête pas de les
confondre. Et il a fallu attendre le
passage en monde virtuel pour que je
réalise que ce gamin en fait c'était OD.
Après, il y a des choses qui changent
jamais hein.
Si je veux
Mais baisez [ __ ]
En plus vous avez genre 40 ans là, donc
ça va. Ah et surtout ce jeu d'acteur par
pitié.
Je te promets de tout faire pour essayer
de comprendre.
Et pour moi, vous décidez quoi
finalement ? Ah
c'est vrai que tu as fait une sacrée
grâce à
Ouais exactement.
appeler quelqu'un pour leur rejecter des
émotions. Bref, sur France 3, on avait
aussi toutes les séries de Nickelodéon,
Dexter ou les Super Nana par exemple,
ainsi que beaucoup de comics le dimanche
dans l'émission F3X ou Bunny Tonic avec
Benten, Team Titan, X-Men Évolution,
Superman, Justice League, la nouvelle
série The Batman et cetera. Alors, je
vais sauter par-dessus France 2 parce
que Cad2a avait quasiment abandonné les
dessins animés pour ne se consacrer
qu'au série live et c'est pas le sujet
du jour. Et à la place, on va aller
direct sur TF. On est à ce moment-là,
1997, le club de roté vient de
disparaître après plus de 10 ans à
l'antenne et est remplacé tout d'abord
par Salut les TS. Mais la disparition de
tous les animés japonais qui ont fait le
succès des émissions jeunesse de TF1
forcément se ressent et les audiences
sont en chute libre. Heureusement,
Pokémon arrivent juste à temps en France
pour sauver leur mich et remonter leur
audience. C'est assez ironique, vous
noterez. Sachant que tout ce foin à la
base, ça partait de ou là là, les
dessins animés japonais, c'est de la
merde, on en veut plus. Bref, et
rapidement, une autre série apparaît
pour surfer sur le succès de Pokémon,
c'est évidemment Digimon.
Moi déjà ce qui m'a toujours faitquer
sur cette série, c'est le générique. Je
veux dire, au début ça commence, c'est
genre ultra moderne, voix de robot.
[Musique]
Tu es le champion. Et d'un coup
dans ton espace virtuel tu
paraît tellement réel
toujours voulu faire de l'opérage
et pour la suite le compositeur il était
au pif
digital pays spécial
au contact cyber digital
et maintenant tu peux me faire un truc
genre jeune brancher un peu électronique
tu vois le délire
digital carte M calculette
cosinus et surtout digital en français.
Enfoncez-vous ça dans le crâne, ça veut
dire doigt hein. On utilise toujours ça
pour faire genre wou c'est digital,
c'est le futur. Mais non, digital ça
veut dire doigt. Un monde digital ça
veut dire un monde plein de doigts.
Bref, l'histoire commence alors que le
héros nous raconte que le monde est au
bord de l'apocalypse. Il y a des
tsunamis debout qui envahissent des
villes. Le climat est complètement
déréglé. Mais lui,
n'étais pas au courant de tout ça parce
que j'étais en camp de vacances.
Comment tu peux pas être au courant de
la fin du monde ? C'est quoi ce camp de
vacances ? Allez les enfants, au
programme cet après-midi, c'est
cache-cache et après on fera un jeu de
piste.
Vous êtes sûr qu'il y a pas quelque
chose que vous devez nous dire ?
Si, c'est on va s'amuser comme si
c'était notre dernier jour sur terre. Et
finalement donc après avoir introduit
beaucoup trop de personnages parmi
lesquels on retrouve tous les clichés
habituels des mangas, le héros, la
garçon manquée, la fille fragile, le
gros nerd, le Vegeta de service. Bref,
soudainement, des météores retombent du
ciel et viennent s'écraser sur la petite
bande.
Bouger. Les météors s'écrasent donc sur
la bande d'amis, mais heureusement ça
n'était pas bien grave car c'était juste
des petites merdes en plastique.
À première vue, on dirait des sortes de
petits appareils numériques.
Achète ma mère. Achète ma mère. Vous
êtes sûr que c'est pas trop agressif
comme politique commerciale ?
Non, continue à tirer.
Et la bande d'amis se fait donc aspirer
dans un autre monde où en se réveillant,
il rencontre de petites créatures
nommées les Digimon. En fait, nous
sommes beaucoup plus que ça et nous
sommes mignons
et fidèles et loyaux avec de beaux
cheveux.
Nous sommes rigolos et adorables
et nous sommes pas chers.
Voilà, je je vous laisse au dessin animé
déjà. Comment ces trucs ont pu survivre
? On dirait une création foirée dans ce
sport. Mon Digimon peut vaincre tous mes
ennemis. Aide-moi à me retourner taille.
Je n'ai pas de bras.
Oui. Et en plus pour pas t'aider Pokémon
au début on t'introduit un seul Pokémon
et il s'appelle Pikachu. Là on t'en
introduit 50 d'un seul coup et ils ont
tous des noms qui finissent en mode.
C'est impossible à retenir. Bref, alors
que chacun des personnages a récupéré
son jouet, un Digimon insecte plus gros
apparaît alors pour attaquer le groupe.
Ah, je savais que j'aurais dû prendre de
l'insecticide.
Bref, évidemment, les Digimon se
défendent mais ne font pas le poids face
à l'immense créature.
Yokomon,
Tonon, parle-moi. Tokomon, qu'est-ce que
tu as ?
Tsunomon, réveille-toi.
Non, pas toi.
Ah [ __ ] c'est quoi ton nom déjà ? Et
alors que tout paraît perdu et que les
bestioles se lancent dans un
ultimassoimon.
Finalement, les Digimon se digivolvent
en leur version plus évolué.
Digivolve
c pas assez compliqué déjà.
Coromonivolve-toi
enum.
Waouh ! Un dinosaure.
Ça c'est original. Par ailleurs, on
apprend dans l'épisode 2 que pour se
digivolver, les Digimon ont besoin de
partager leur énergie avec les
propriétaires.
Et pour être sûr que ça réussisse, il
faut que je partage ton énergie.
Mais comment tu prends mon énergie ? Je
t'expliquerai ça plus tard.
Et quoi plus tard ? Pourquoi pas
maintenant ?
Je te remercie pour mes pouvoirs
magiques. Comment ça merci ? C'est quoi
l'arnaque ?
Je t'expliquerai plus tard. Taille.
D'accord. Coromon. Mais c'est bizarre
parce que depuis que tu es là, j'ai mal
au cœur. J'ai des cheveux blancs et je
sais du nez.
Tout est normal taille, ne te pose pas
de questions.
Alors, j'ai pas eu le loisir de mat la
série en entière. J'ai juste zappé
dedans. Globalement l'histoire c'est
qu'on suit les enfants qui sont perdus
dans le Digimonde et essayer d'en
sortir. Et évidemment au fur et à
mesure, on va voir évoluer les
bestioles, découvrir des nouveaux
personnages et apprendre les enjeux de
ce monde. Par exemple, on y aperçoit
quelques épisodes plus tard le premier
gros méchant de la série qui s'appelle
Devilmon.
Le méchant,
le méchant.
J'aurais jamais deviné que c'était le
méchant. Bon, alors après Devilmon,
c'est pas le vrai méchant final de la
série. Le boss de fin s'appelle
Apocalymon. C'est très très Littéral
Monéc. Alors d'ailleurs la série se
finit au bout de 54 épisodes sur un
affrontement à la Final Fantasy dans
l'espace avec tout le monde qui vole. On
a on a balancé toute la purée du Japon.
Enfin, il y a 3D, il y a des mécures, il
y a des gky, des furies et les boules de
gras, c'est devenu des
Oh,
waouh, c'est W Fon. Et d'ailleurs, on se
foutait de la gueule de Pokémon avec les
Pokémon Trousceau de clé et compagnie,
mais Digimon, ils ont rien à leur
envier. Regardez ça. Qu'est-ce que c'est
que un carnet d'adresse, un calendrier,
c'est une calculette et ça c'est c'est
littéralement du carton. Oui, parce qu'à
la base, on a pensé à tous les gens qui
font du cosplay et parce que
non, on a plus d'idée en fait. Alors,
visiblement, c'est la dernière saison de
Digimon qui s'appelle Appmon et ça a
l'air d'être du même niveau que Yu-Gi-Oh
à Mobyette.
Dans les trèsfonds d'Internet, une
terrible créature tapis dans le dark web
manigance un plan maiavellque.
Le dark web,
c'est quoi cette saison ? Digimon contre
Daesh et les réseaux pédophiles. Enfin
bref, donc et au passage, je tiens à
souligner mais à quel point les héros ne
servent à rien. Je veux dire, dans
Pokémon, les dresseurs étaient là pour
leur dire quoi faire à leur Pokémon.
Mais ici, les Digimon, ils se
débrouillent tout seul, ils se battent
tout seul, ils sont complètement
indépendants. Du coup, tous les héros
ben allez Coromon.
Euh ben ben vas-y bah toi bref, on
pourrait continuer à parler de ça
pendant des heures. Il y a plein de
séries qu'on a pas aborder par manque de
temps. Je peux pas tout citer et je sais
que vous allez tous être en train de me
dire "E tu as pas parlé de docteur
Globul, de Arnold, de Jimmy Neutron, de
Oggi et les Cafard, de Martha Myst ou de
Total Spice qui a donné le fétiche du
latex à toute une génération. Les années
2000 étaient riches en contenu, d'autant
plus que c'est dans ces années-là que
sont aussi apparues les chaînes câblées.
Contrairement à nous qui n'avions que
six chaînes, vous avez eu Cartoon
Network, Canalg, Disney Channel, la
chaîne Manga, Yuli, je sais pas comment
on dit, Télétoon et cetera. Bref, encore
plein d'autres choses dont on parlera
dans d'autres épisodes, même si au fond
entre nous hein, tout le monde sait que
bah les années 90 c'était quand même
vachement mieux, hein. Ah ben voilà, ben
ça marche finalement. D'accord. Non,
parce qu'on est d'accord que ce genre de
détecteur, ça existe pas. C'est c'est un
détecteur de fumée.
Ah mais pourquoi ça sonne ? Oh merde !
Libre de droit,
générique. Libre de droit,
libre de droit. Cette chanson est à moi.
YouTube l'enlève pas. C'est libre de
droit. Libre de droit.
Salut à tous. J'espère que cet épisode
vous a plu. Juste un petit mot pour
finir pour remercier les gens de chez
Medatoon qui nous ont permis de diffuser
quelques extraits des épisodes de CODC
qui nous a permis de faire cet épisode.
Sachez qu'ils ont une chaîne YouTube où
vous pourrez retrouver tous les épisodes
de Codoko en excellente qualité et le
lien est dans la description. Et pareil
aussi pour la chaîne Génération Club de
RTé. Je mets aussi le lien dans la
description. Ils nous ont aussi laissé
utiliser quelques-uns des rush en bonne
qualité de leur chaîne YouTube. Donc
merci à eux deux. Les liens sont dans la
description. N'hésitez pas à aller voir
si vous avez envie de voir des vieux
épisodes du club de roté ou de Code
Yoko. Bisous à tous, salut et à la
prochaine pour une autre vidéo. Ciao !